before talking more about inequality I
think it it's worth talking about the
difference of what the difference
between wealth wealth and income wealth
and income because I think they often
get confused in conversations about well
wealth and income and also about
inequality as you can imagine these two
things move together you tend to
associate someone who has more wealth
has a higher income or someone who has a
higher income is more likely to have
more wealth but these are not the same
things wealth wealth is you could view
it as the capital or the assets that you
own so this is the value value of
capital capital and assets that you own
capital and assets that are owned while
this is how much is made in a certain
period of time so amount amount made in
a certain certain period and they tend
to move together but not always so let's
take an example where they don't move
together so let's say that there's a
retiree a retiree might have a lot of
wealth because they've had a whole
lifetime of income to save so let's say
that your grandparents or let's just say
your your grand your grandfather has a
wealth so their total assets his total
assets let's say he has a million
dollars a million dollars in total
assets but he's not working anymore he's
retired so his total income his total
income is the return that he gets on
that 1 million dollars and let's say
that he has invested in reasonably safe
things and some bonds and whatever else
and so he's getting a let's say he's
getting a 3% return after taxes on his
wealth so his income is going to be
$30,000 per year now let's say you let's
say this is you
over here let's say you you're maybe
you're you're just out of college maybe
you actually have more debt than you
have assets so maybe your wealth could
even be your wealth if you if you know
say you have a $20,000 car but you owe
$40,000 for your college loans you might
have negative wealth you might have a
wealth of negative wealth of negative
$20,000 but you that that education was
to good use you were able to get a
really good job and you are now making
let's say you're making $80,000 a year
so this is a situation where the younger
person they actually have more
liabilities than they have assets could
even have negative wealth but has a
reasonably high income while someone
who's older and retired could have a lot
of wealth but a lower income now as you
can imagine this isn't you know this is
kind of I have drawn two extremes here
between a younger person making a good
amount of money but they have some debt
and an older person who is just living
on the returns from there from there
from there from their accumulated wealth
over their lifetime now as you can
imagine these do these do think these
two things do start to correlate
especially for example let's say wealth
got really big let's say instead of your
grandfather saving 1 million over his
lifetime let's say it was 10 million
let's say it's 10 million and he's
investing it in the exact same way so
now that 3 percent of 10 million he has
300 thousand dollars per year to live
off of so obviously as wealth grows the
income from wealth the income from that
capital will grow and at some point that
income could be larger than what you
might be able to make purely from labor
but the whole point of this video is to
at least highlight the difference
sometimes when people talk about
inequality or disparities they'll talk
about accumulating wealth in a frag in a
segment of the population while other
times they will talk about accumulating
the national income be going more and
more towards the top 1% or top 10% or
the top
or tile or whatever and they often move
together but it's important to realize
the difference